let's talk about number one do a friends
reunion okay
oh okay so Jen Aniston sort of halfway
kind of stuck true to that little
statement that she made on The Ellen
Show earlier this month check out her
and Lisa Kudrow celebrating Courtney
Cox's 55th birthday together over the
weekend
Courtney wrote quote how lucky am I to
celebrate my birthday with these two I
love you girls so much I just have all
the Phoebe Monica Rachel feels right now
the whole thing was the best experience
that I could possibly imagine I felt
very lucky to have been a part of that
show and everything kind of seems to
pale in comparison whenever I read
comedies I'm just like can't compare
could a real friends reunion actually
happened though for 16 years we've been
asking you about a friends rebooting now
you said maybe and now I know and now
you did this to us you did this well you
know know was getting me nowhere maybe
was getting me nowhere so I don't know I
thought I'd try us see what happened
anything had happened I have no idea
though there's no plans in the immediate
future
so everyone calm down yeah or innkeeper
don't and don't stay excited then
possibly something will happen be so fun
fun for us it's very was really fun
being feeling okay I have a theory and I
might be totally wrong but Taylor Swift
could bring them together remember her
aw cover yeah top corner at the cast of
friends there are still a lot of clues
in the cover we haven't gotten answers
about I did think maybe they could
appear and they you need to calm down
video
mostly because the tea set in the video
is the same tea set as in season 10
episode 11 of friends it's just tea oh
and it can't be a coincidence that Ellen
Pompeo is also in that same episode of
friends taylor loves Ellen and Grey's
Anatomy and yeah Ellen and Sandro have a
pin on Taylor's jacket right next to the
friends cast have I lost my mind
do I need to calm down it's possible but
the pins have to mean something right
and this year marks a very big
anniversary for friends 25 years in
September since that show aired Wow
I know that's amazing that's not that
crazy with or without Taylor I feel like
the friends reunion of her dreams could
happen let me know what you guys think
though and for all the latest on friends
and Taylor Swift keep it locked to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now
[Music]